[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome channel awesome
Zorba report your source for everything
happening around the world and pop
culture in entertainment news
I'm Heather roofs and I'm Anna Wade and
this is your news for Monday July 9th
first up for this week you wanted to
talk about new casting news Star Wars
Episode nine has a cast of one for now
not they've just added one to their cast
the first confirmed cast member is going
to be Keri Russell joining Star Wars day
I'm very excited however we don't have
that much information on which character
she's going to be playing if this is a
whole and already established character
of the universe or if it's a new one
what we do know is that in the release
it has been stated that it is a heavy
action site seems that she's going to be
doing so that's also go on uh so what
kind of let you know what we know as we
learn it but for now I am very excited
about this news and we only have to wait
until December 2019 to see the movie I
know which is crazy that's crazy
[Laughter]
also this week we got an announcement
that there's going to be a child's play
reboots
which seems kind of odd because first of
all it's getting fast-tracked like they
want this thing made and they want it
made like yesterday it's starting to
film in the fall so they don't have much
time to pull everything together
um so speculation is that they might be
doing this because this year is the 30th
anniversary of the franchise so maybe
they're trying to pull something
together really quickly to celebrate
that but like you're a little late if
you're starting to film this fall like
it's already past yeah but then the
other thing that's little strange is
that it is being rebooted as child's
play and it's been the
Chucky's franchise now fur for a while
yeah I mean I'm not huge into horror but
from what I was picking up on and
reading like it's still kind of going on
they've been doing direct direct to DVD
and on-demand stuff for a while now and
they've been doing fairly well yeah the
franchise is actually um kept the same
continuity since the 80s so they've been
keeping it up they've been producing
some films still like in 2017 I think
was one one of the latest ones that was
released and now they're just gonna
reboot it and that's when they were
calling it the studio was calling it a
reboot hmm with this is another
interesting thing with a new
technologically advanced doll there's a
tiny doll running at you with a knife it
doesn't really matter if he also has a
laser beam the fact that a doll is
chasing after you is the creepy part
right and I think it's almost even
creepier if it's not technologically
advanced it is if it's it's kind of
creepy or if it's an older toy right
because it has to it has to be more
creative with how it's gonna kill you
yeah just like sync up with your smart
home and set your house on fire or
something like it they have to
physically come after you with a knife
yeah in order ex-wife it's that chase if
the chase man is gay right all right
yeah I'm not sure why that makes it
scarier but man right I don't know I
guess we'll just have to wait and see
for more news about this but it didn't
seem like it was received pretty well
but and I can understand right there's
some history and it's been following the
same continuity since the 80s
so why why step on in here and reboot it
I don't know we're just gonna have to
see you he reminds me has both layer
which reboot a little bit and huh or
sequel I guess where they had you know
the thing that made the original Blair
Witch so scary is that there was all
a blur between if it was real or not
not seeing the monster was really scary
you know like what's chasing you with
that suspense and then the new one
didn't really have that anymore and so
they had to make up with it with all
these technological like cameras and
angles and everything and so it kind of
feels like that and way up and if that
magic is lost right you know yeah I
don't know if any of you are fans of the
Chucky series franchise let us know in
the comments below yeah because also
this week we got an announcements and
also why I am wearing this hat because
of you guys so this week at the Anime
Expo sunrise made an announcement that
they are Co producing a live-action
movie with legendary pictures which
seems awesome but also seems like it can
go terribly wrong very fast I mean we've
seen some interesting American anime
remakes movies so I'm hoping it's not
gonna be like that my little Gundam
fanatic heart Holmes it's gonna be
wonderful
the good news is that legendary has
already proven that they can kind of at
least technologically do mechs they did
Pacific Rim so we know they can do that
kind of storyline and have the
technology to do it well like say what
you want about Pacific Rim but it was
still a fun like robot fighting robot
movie um one of my many concerns though
is that since legendary does have
Pacific Rim they're gonna try to do some
kind of like weird Pacific Rim Gundam
crossover thing we're like the jaegers
influence the Gundams or the Gundams
influence the jaegers are good night
they might cuz I mean actually in
Pacific Rim - you see a little statue of
a Gundam for like a hot second so
Gundams are in the Pacific Rim universe
or at least the series is I don't I
don't know oh but right now we have
almost no in
about it we do know that it's going to
be set in the universal century so if
you are Gundam fan you know what that
means if you're not it's the original
timeline that the condom universe is set
in is in the universal century and it's
obviously going to be about war and they
did have a little synopsis that it will
involve people moving to space and then
wanting their independence from the
earth so it sounds like maybe it's a
rehash of the original series in the
original movie but we have no details
about it yet and I will be following
this like a hawk what is happening with
this yeah because I am excited but very
very cautious about it right now
it's gonna be nerve-wracking I mean we
have seen a live-action Canadian TV
series done with Sun Rise and it was it
was G Savior so yeah but also what I'm
coming away with this also announced
this week HBO has ordered a pilot for
this series low Spooky's which is going
to be a spanish-language series on HBO
we're out to you by Fred Armisen and
Lorne Michaels which I love everything
involved so far all of those checking a
bunch of boxes for me um Fred Armisen is
going to be writing a coke executive
producing and also he's starring in it
playing Tico and Lorne Michaels is
co-executive producing it on a fabrica
and also Julio Torres are also going to
be in on the writing they're going to
co-writing co-starring as well they each
have parts of their own and and
co-producing so it's gonna be a really
interesting kind of groupthink type of
comedy series it sounds like which I'm
very excited for especially after a
Portlandia is now officially ended so we
can see what's next for Fred Armisen and
this series was originally billed as
Mexico City only good things happen so
it's interesting to see that they're
really embracing the the Spanish title
and it sounds like it's going to be
completely in Spanish which is also
super exciting for HBO to have done and
we can look forward to that pilot in
November oh no they have a full cast and
the cast breakdown and everything I
don't want to give anything away
obviously cuz working on fits just a hop
skip and a jump away so I can wait to
find out more about the series but the
cast looks fantastic it's got a lot of
SNL people already it sounds like from
the writing room and producing so I'm
sure it's just gonna be a hilarious romp
and I'm very excited for it's there
basically the plot sounds like it's a
bunch of people that are horror film
flicks like really into like that kind
of stuff and they decide to have a
company come together so we'll see how
that all comes together soon awesome
yeah um lastly this week Funko announced
and on a blog post that they are
releasing serials that are absolutely
named Funk O's I know that was fun that
was a documentary there is a documentary
on Netflix
about the history of Funko on Funko pops
kind of like hinted at it like you saw
them tasting some cereals and they
talked a little bit about it but like
it's here it's happening comin right now
there are six that are coming out like
soon it said July yeah and a lot of them
are focused in mall stores so one of
them is Mega Man and that's going to be
available at Gamestop cuphead and mug
man which is gonna be available at Hot
Topic and then Freddie and a separate
serial Jason are going to be available
at FY ease golem like what are the rings
is gonna be available at box box lunch
and then lastly Freddie like the mascot
of
Funko pops is going to be available on
their website so what
maybe try some cereals exactly
collectors get to it we know you're
going well that's exciting I had a fun
way to end this week we will definitely
see you next week or on top 5 otherwise
you can have stuff on social media let
us know what we missed this week and
what you'd like to see us cover next
Heather where's that for you you can
follow me on instagram twitter or twitch
where I now streaming on Tuesday and
Thursday nights yes and you can find me
on Facebook Twitter or Instagram that's
can be it from us in the meantime can
you beam us up
[Applause]
you